[Music]
Kylie Jenner is busy prepping for
motherhood a Kardashian source tells et
that she is excited about this new
chapter and has been quote taking time
out of the spotlight to prepare for her
new life as a mother adding Kylie has
had her moments of being nervous but she
knows she has the best teachers to guide
her through being a great mother her own
mother and sisters the source also
revealed that the beauty moguls dad
Caitlyn Jenner wasn't initially pleased
about her daughter's pregnancy news
explaining that she's quote hesitant
about Kylie's boyfriend the baby's
father rapper Travis Scott but one
person who is proud of the reality star
is her mom Kris Jenner ET sat down with
the famous momager in October and while
she didn't address her daughter's
pregnancy directly she did say her
daughter is capable of handling anything
I think she is a very strong she's
really I think equipped to handle
whatever comes her way I'm so proud of
that kid she's a good good girl with a
big heart
[Music]